toxic masculinity is one of the most  evil times I have ever heard there's no  such thing as toxic masculinity there's  just literally toxic individuals what it  means to be a man is now being branded  as toxic whether it's being competitive  aggressive we are now teaching boys and  men to be softer they're trying to turn  men into women and I think the reason  they want to do this is because it's the  men that go to war it's the men that  fight the Tyranny it's not women we're  emotionally not resilient we're either  physically fit enough to fight the  powers that be it's the men that do that  so when the men are feminize the  government those in charge can get away  with whatever the hell they want to get  away with